Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. There is a certain amount of satisfaction felt by all in attendance. The Dallas Police have done an incredible, some would even say a near impossible job over the last eleven and a half hours. In that short span since the President's murder, they have apprehended the man they believe is responsible and amassed evidence against him that is destined to withstand years of intense scrutiny. Despite the thousands of government man hours yet to come, the basis of the case against Oswald is collected and assembled by the Dallas police
感谢收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需每周额外剧集、无广告收听、抢先观看系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请前往 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。在场的所有人都感到某种程度的满足。达拉斯警方在过去十一个半小时里完成了一项令人难以置信、甚至有人会说是近乎不可能的任务。在总统遇刺后的这段短时间内，他们已经抓获了他们认为负有责任的人，并收集了足以经受多年严密审查的证据。尽管未来还需要政府投入数千小时的人力，但针对奥斯瓦尔德的案件基础已经由达拉斯警方收集并整理完毕。
in these first crucial hours. It is a feat the world will soon forget. That is Vincent Bugliosi in Parkland, his account of kennedy's assassination and three days that follow it and it is his judgment on the performance of the dallas police on the 22nd of november the day that kennedy is shot but dominic we have now reached the 23rd of november so it's the day after kennedy's assassination and i mean i know the bugleji has spent years and years investigating this so but i'm sure that listeners would like to know whether you concur with his judgment on the performance of the dallas police do you feel qualified to pass judgment on it tom regular listeners to the rest of Cistern will know that we feel qualified to pronounce all kinds of historical fields of inquiry.
在最初这几个关键小时内。这是一个世界很快就会遗忘的壮举。这是文森特·布格里奥西（Vincent Bugliosi）在帕克兰医院的记录，是他对肯尼迪遇刺及其后三天事件的叙述，也是他对达拉斯警方在11月22日（肯尼迪遇刺当天）表现的评价。但多米尼克，我们现在已经到了11月23日，也就是肯尼迪遇刺后的第二天。我知道布格里奥西花了多年时间调查此事，但我相信听众们想知道你是否认同他对达拉斯警方表现的评价。你觉得你有资格对此做出评价吗，汤姆？《历史的余味》的常客们都知道，我们认为自己有资格对各种历史研究领域发表看法。
And this is no different. There is one thing I would certainly quibble with Vincent Bugliosi on there. He says they had compiled evidence which is destined to withstand decades of scrutiny, the truth of the matter is that actually for decades, that evidence has been pulled apart, reinterpreted, twisted, questioned, undermined. And although I agree with him that the Dallas police worked remarkably competently and efficiently, actually, to apprehend a suspect, to compile a case, to put together the evidence and so on and so forth the fact of the matter is that what happens in the next couple of days means that all of their work will be produced put in a kind of shadow put in a shadow exactly so i actually i think he's being unduly you know to write as though this is a an open shut case and there's nothing to be asked about it is to miss the fact, willfully miss the fact, that for tens and tens of millions of people, there are always questions about this. Now, whether those questions are justified is a different matter.
这一点也不例外。有一点我肯定要和文森特·布格里奥西商榷。他说他们收集的证据注定能经受几十年的审查，但事实是，几十年来，这些证据一直被拆解、重新解读、扭曲、质疑和削弱。虽然我同意他的观点，即达拉斯警方在抓捕嫌疑人、整理案件、汇总证据等方面表现得非常称职和高效，但事实是，接下来几天发生的事情意味着他们所有的工作都将被蒙上一层阴影。完全被蒙上阴影。所以我认为他表现得过于……你知道，写得好像这是一个盖棺定论的案件，没有什么可质疑的，这忽略了一个事实，即故意忽略了一个事实：对于成千上万的人来说，关于这件事总是有疑问的。至于这些疑问是否合理，那是另一回事。
I guess the salient fact, though, is that he is pointing out that, you know, within less than a day, the Dallas police have compiled this case against the man they think is guilty of shooting the president. So what do they know at this point about Oswald's movements before the assassination? Have they kind of looked into that? Have they drawn up a picture of what his movements might have been? They have, of course. So this is the kind of picture they have. They know that Oswald, who had previously spent time in the Soviet Union, is married to a Russian woman called Marina, and that she lives in Irving, which is kind of suburban metropolitan fringes of Dallas. And she's with a Quaker, isn't she? Called Ruth Payne. Who is very interested in Russian.
我想，最突出的事实是，他指出在不到一天的时间里，达拉斯警方就已经针对他们认为枪杀总统的嫌疑人整理好了案件。那么，他们此时对奥斯瓦尔德在刺杀前的行踪了解多少？他们调查过吗？他们是否勾勒出了他可能的行踪？当然调查过。这就是他们掌握的情况：他们知道奥斯瓦尔德之前在苏联待过，娶了一位名叫玛丽娜的俄罗斯女性，她住在欧文，那是达拉斯郊区大都市的边缘地带。她和一位名叫露丝·佩恩（Ruth Payne）的贵格会教徒住在一起，对吧？她对俄语非常感兴趣。
She's a Russian teacher. Yes, exactly. That's how they become friends. They know that Oswald usually visited his wife in Irving at the weekends, but very unusually. Well, the only time I think. Exactly. Had visited her on a Thursday during the week. Had left his rented accommodation in Oak Cliff, Dallas to go out to Irving to see his wife. They know because she has told them that he left his wedding ring behind. Again, it's weird, isn't it? These parallel stories. So Jackie taking her ring off and
她是一位俄语老师。是的，没错。他们就是这样成为朋友的。他们知道奥斯瓦尔德通常在周末去欧文看望妻子，但非常反常的是——我想这是唯一一次——他在周四工作日期间去看望了她。他离开了在达拉斯橡崖（Oak Cliff）租住的地方，去欧文看望妻子。他们知道，因为她告诉他们，他把结婚戒指留下了。这又很奇怪，不是吗？这些平行的故事。杰奎琳摘下戒指，
leaving it on her dead husband's finger, the symbolism of it all. They know that he left early on the Friday morning with a long package wrapped up in brown paper to get a lift from a neighbour called Wesley Frazier into Dallas to work. And that when Wesley Frazier asked Lee Harvey Oswald what he is carrying, Lee Harvey Oswald said, curtain rods. They know that he arrived at the Texas Book Depository at 7.52 in the morning, which is on the corner of Houston and Elm overlooking Dealey Plaza, as we said. And unusually, again, he walked away from Wesley Fraser as they walked away from the car with his package. He kind of went off to the book depository.
把它留在她已故丈夫的手指上，这一切的象征意义。他们知道他在周五清晨带着一个用牛皮纸包裹的长条包裹离开，搭乘邻居韦斯利·弗雷泽（Wesley Frazier）的车去达拉斯上班。当韦斯利·弗雷泽问李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德带着什么时，李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德说是窗帘杆。他们知道他在早上7点52分到达了德克萨斯州教科书仓库大楼，正如我们所说，它位于休斯顿街和埃尔姆街的拐角处，俯瞰着迪利广场。而且反常的是，当他们离开车时，他带着包裹走开了，没有和韦斯利·弗雷泽一起走。他径直去了教科书仓库。
They know that he spent the morning working at the book depository, that he went up and down between the different floors, that he spent time on the sixth floor from where they think the shots were taken. They know that at 12 o'clock, half an hour before Kennedy was assassinated, he was seen on the sixth floor by one of his bosses, that some of the others were going downstairs for lunch, that he did not go downstairs for lunch, and that he asked for the elevator gate, that's the gate on the lifts, to be closed. Then there was a blank, but they know that at 12 31 this police motorbike officer marion baker went into the texas book depository looking for the suspect and that he and the superintendent
他们知道他在教科书仓库工作了一上午，他在不同楼层之间走动，他在他们认为开枪的六楼待过。他们知道在12点，即肯尼迪遇刺前半小时，他被其中一位老板看到在六楼，当时其他人正下楼去吃午饭，但他没有下楼吃午饭，他还要求把电梯门（即升降梯的门）关上。然后有一段空白，但他们知道在12点31分，警察摩托车手马里昂·贝克（Marion Baker）进入德克萨斯州教科书仓库寻找嫌疑人，他和主管
bumped into lee harvey oswald the superintendent said oh it's fine i know him he works here and the lee harvey oswald then left the building was gone from the building no later than about 12 35 he is the only employee of the texas book depository to have left the building no later than about 1235. He's the only employee of the Texas Book Depository to have left the building after the assassination. They know that at 1239, he caught a bus going west on Elm Street, and he was seen by somebody on the bus who knew him looking kind of, she said, scruffy and kind of distracted and a bit wild-eyed. They know that at 12.46, because of course in the chaos following the assassination, there's all kinds of traffic jams and congestion and sort of confusion.
撞见了李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德。主管说：“哦，没关系，我认识他，他在这里工作。”然后李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德离开了大楼，在大约12点35分之前就离开了。他是德克萨斯州教科书仓库唯一在大约12点35分之前离开大楼的员工。他是刺杀事件后唯一离开大楼的员工。他们知道在12点39分，他搭乘了一辆向西行驶在埃尔姆街的公交车，车上有人认识他，那人说他看起来很邋遢、心不在焉，眼神有点狂野。他们知道在12点46分，因为刺杀后的混乱，到处都是交通堵塞和混乱。
They know that Oswald got off the bus and unusually did something that he never normally did because he doesn't have very much money at all, that he hailed a cab that took him to Oak Cliff. Then he got out of the cab, then he went home, changed his trousers, and that's what brought him to the attention of Officer Tippett. And they know, you know, there was no doubt in their minds that Oswald is the man who shot Officer Tippett
他们知道奥斯瓦尔德下了公交车，做了一件他平时从不做的事，因为他根本没什么钱，他叫了一辆出租车带他去橡崖。然后他下了出租车，回家换了裤子，这引起了蒂皮特（Tippett）警官的注意。他们知道，毫无疑问，奥斯瓦尔德就是枪杀蒂皮特警官的人，
and then fled without buying a ticket into this... Into the movie theatre. Movie theatre where he was subsequently arrested. And that, of course, he fought the police and tried to pull a gun when they arrested him. By Saturday morning, Fritz has also caught Oswald out in two lies. Now, for an experienced investigator like Captain Fritz of the Dallas Police Department, he knows that unless the circumstances are very unusual, somebody who has been falsely accused does not generally tell small lies because it's not in their interest to do so. Unless, you know, you're trying to cover up something else in your life, the chances are that you will tell the truth because you know beyond any doubt, because you know you didn't do it, you know that the truth will exonerate you. Oswald has already told two lies.
然后他没买票就逃进了电影院。他在电影院随后被捕。当然，他在被捕时反抗警察并试图拔枪。到周六早上，弗里茨（Fritz）也抓住了奥斯瓦尔德的两个谎言。对于达拉斯警察局的弗里茨队长这样经验丰富的调查员来说，他知道除非情况非常特殊，否则被诬告的人通常不会撒小谎，因为这不符合他们的利益。除非你在掩盖生活中的其他事情，否则你很可能会说实话，因为你毫无疑问地知道自己没做过，你知道真相会还你清白。奥斯瓦尔德已经撒了两个谎。
He's lied about whether or not he brought any curtain rods to work. Of course, if they are just curtain rods, what's the issue? Yeah, there is no gain to him in lying about it. And secondly, he has denied that he's ever bought a gun. And then of course they say to him, well, what about your revolver? Oh yeah, well, that's not a gun. And when they say to him, the mail order gun in the name of A. Heidel, he denies anything about it. Now, if Oswald had bought the gun perfectly innocently, if it's not the murder weapon, if he had not shot Kennedy, there is no reason again for him to lie about this because of course, gun ownership in Texas is hardly unusual. So the police that morning, Saturday morning, they are in no doubt whatsoever that Oswald is the man.
他撒谎说他是否带了窗帘杆去上班。当然，如果那只是窗帘杆，有什么问题呢？是的，撒谎对他没有任何好处。其次，他否认自己买过枪。然后他们问他：“那你的左轮手枪呢？”“哦，那个啊，那不是枪。”当他们问他关于以A·海德尔（A. Heidel）名义邮购的那把枪时，他全盘否认。现在，如果奥斯瓦尔德是完全无辜地买了那把枪，如果那不是凶器，如果他没有枪杀肯尼迪，他再次没有理由撒谎，因为在德克萨斯州拥有枪支并不罕见。所以那天早上，周六早上，警方毫无疑问地认为奥斯瓦尔德就是凶手。
And what about the kind of the justice system? Are they convinced by the evidence? Do they go public with it? Totally convinced. The DA, Henry Wade, at one o'clock that afternoon, he goes to the press. The press is still there, by the way. Of course they are. It's a really important point, Biss, when we get to Jack Ruby.
那司法系统呢？他们对证据确信无疑吗？他们公开了吗？完全确信。地方检察官亨利·韦德（Henry Wade）在当天下午一点向媒体发布了消息。顺便说一句，媒体还在那里。当然还在。这是一个非常重要的点，比斯（Biss），当我们谈到杰克·鲁比（Jack Ruby）时。
The press is still there. Great hordes of them in the police headquarters in downtown dallas and dominic it's fair to say also that of course this is generating international as well as merely american interest and that already particularly in europe and actually particularly in france i gather all kinds of conspiracy theories are starting to circulate in a way that they're not openly in America at this point. Yeah. So in France, lots of people are saying it's a conspiracy. The French papers, for example. Don't forget the United States has had quite disobliging coverage in European papers for a couple of years because of civil rights. So there's been a heavy emphasis in European papers
媒体还在那里。大批媒体聚集在达拉斯市中心的警察总部。多米尼克，公平地说，这不仅在美国，而且在国际上也引起了关注。特别是在欧洲，实际上特别是在法国，我了解到各种阴谋论开始流传，而在美国此时还没有公开流传。是的。所以在法国，很多人说这是一场阴谋。例如法国报纸。别忘了，由于民权问题，美国在欧洲报纸上的报道一直很不讨好。所以欧洲报纸非常强调
on the racism of the South, the abuse demonstrators martin luther king put in prison in birmingham all of that kind of stuff so as soon as kennedy is shot a lot of the european press say oh america is crazy it's full of crazy people and conspirators and so this also is part of the context for it that they are aware that they have to present a watertight case because the eyes of the world as well as of amer America are on them. Absolutely. It's why they are so open with the press, because it is so important to them that there not be a hint of suspicion about this. So one o'clock that afternoon, the district attorney, Henry Wade, he tells the press, he says, we have the suspect, he's been charged,
南方的种族主义、对示威者的虐待、马丁·路德·金在伯明翰入狱等等。所以肯尼迪一被枪杀，许多欧洲媒体就说：“哦，美国疯了，到处都是疯子和阴谋家。”所以这也是背景的一部分，他们意识到必须提交一份无懈可击的案件，因为全世界和美国的目光都盯着他们。绝对是。这就是他们对媒体如此开放的原因，因为对他们来说，不留下一丝怀疑至关重要。所以当天下午一点，地方检察官亨利·韦德告诉媒体，他说：“我们已经抓到了嫌疑人，他已被起诉，
we expect a trial in mid-Januaryuary and I will be asking for the death penalty. So about 15 minutes after that, Oswald's mother, Marguerite, and his wife, Russian wife, Marina, are shown in to see him. His mother's a terrible woman, isn't she? She is. Yeah. She's a bad mother, I think it's fair to say. Very, very self-centered. It's all about her. Very self-centered and incredibly flaky. Marina, of course, this very young Russian who he met in Minsk. Who doesn't really speak English. She is totally out of her depth and bewildered by the whole thing. But here is what is really interesting. They go in and they have this very desultory conversation. He asks about the kids
我们预计在一月中旬进行审判，我将要求判处死刑。”大约15分钟后，奥斯瓦尔德的母亲玛格丽特（Marguerite）和他的俄罗斯妻子玛丽娜（Marina）被带去见他。他母亲是个糟糕的女人，不是吗？是的。我想说她是个糟糕的母亲。非常非常以自我为中心。一切都围绕着她。非常以自我为中心，而且极其不可靠。玛丽娜，当然，这个他在明斯克认识的非常年轻的俄罗斯人。她不太会说英语。她完全不知所措，对整件事感到困惑。但真正有趣的是：他们进去进行了这次非常散漫的谈话。他问起孩子们
and stuff like this. Marina, at this point, believes her husband is guilty. Because he's not protesting. Because she knows him. She knows what a spiky, difficult, anti-authority, sort of aggressive man Lee Oswald is. And when she sees him sullen, all of this this she thinks this is very weird she knows that if he were innocent he would be shouting and roaring about his rights and protesting and having to be dragged in and out and all of this thing and when she sees him react like this she thinks he's guilty now the other person who comes along that afternoon is his brother robert robert similarly finds Lee's demeanor very peculiar. He is disturbed by it
之类的事情。玛丽娜此时相信她的丈夫是有罪的。因为他没有抗议。因为她了解他。她知道李·奥斯瓦尔德是一个多么尖刻、麻烦、反权威、有点好斗的人。当她看到他闷闷不乐时，她觉得这非常奇怪。她知道如果他是无辜的，他会大喊大叫维护自己的权利，会抗议，会被拖进拖出，所有这些。当她看到他这样反应时，她认为他有罪。那天下午来的另一个人是他的兄弟罗伯特（Robert）。罗伯特同样觉得李的行为非常古怪。他对此感到不安，
because he says that his brother is like a robot just answering questions mechanically, not showing any emotion, not doing what Robert hoped he would be doing, which is saying, they've got the wrong man. You've got to get me out of here. You've got to get me a lawyer. It's as though Lee's not really interested. The president of the Dallas Bar Association comes along and he says, do you want my help in finding you a lawyer? People are actually bending over backwards to try and make sure this all runs properly. He too says, I found Lee Harvey Oswald very calm, not frightened, not angry, just impassive, unreadable. And also he just wants this weird lawyer in New York, doesn't he? John Abt.
因为他说他的兄弟就像个机器人，机械地回答问题，没有表现出任何情绪，没有做罗伯特希望他做的事，即说：“他们抓错人了。你得把我弄出去。你得给我找个律师。”就好像李根本不感兴趣。达拉斯律师协会主席来了，他说：“你需要我帮你找律师吗？”人们实际上在竭尽全力确保这一切正常进行。他也说：“我发现李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德非常冷静，不害怕，不愤怒，只是冷漠、难以捉摸。”而且他只想找纽约那个奇怪的律师，对吧？约翰·阿布特（John Abt）。
Yes. He keeps saying, I need this guy Abt who he's read about, a sort of civil liberties lawyer. And the Dallas people say, well, we'll get you a good lawyer down here. We'll find you a lawyer. No, no, no. I must have this guy. By evening, there were two more developments in the case, both of which seemed to the police to confirm what they already believe.
是的。他一直说：“我需要这个我读到过的叫阿布特的人，一个民权律师。”达拉斯的人说：“好吧，我们会在这里给你找个好律师。我们会给你找个律师。”“不，不，不。我必须要有这个人。”到了晚上，案件又有了两个进展，这两个进展在警方看来都证实了他们已经相信的事情。
One is they have found a money order for the rifle, the money order that Mr. Heidel used to buy it from Chicago, and the money order handwriting, the analysis shows that this is Lee Harvey Oswald's handwriting. Secondly, they find a photograph of Lee Harvey Oswald in the backyard of his home with a rifle and two communist papers. And it seems to be the same rifle. And they showed the photograph to Oswald and Oswald says, that's not my face. It's a fake face. They've put somebody else's face on top of my body. And now there's been lots of discussion about this ever since this features in Oliver Stone's film, JFK. I think the general consensus now is that this is not a fake photograph. There's been very, very detailed analysis of it in the last few years,
一个是他们找到了购买步枪的汇票，即海德尔先生用来从芝加哥购买步枪的汇票，笔迹分析显示这是李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德的笔迹。其次，他们发现了一张李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德在自家后院拿着步枪和两份共产主义报纸的照片。看起来是同一把步枪。他们把照片给奥斯瓦尔德看，奥斯瓦尔德说：“那不是我的脸。那是假脸。他们把别人的脸贴在我的身体上了。”从那以后，关于这一点有很多讨论，这出现在奥利弗·斯通（Oliver Stone）的电影《刺杀肯尼迪》（JFK）中。我认为现在的普遍共识是，这不是一张假照片。过去几年里，人们对它进行了非常非常详细的分析，
which suggests that it is actually an authentic photograph. It doesn't mean that he did it, by the way. But this is clearly his defense, isn't it? The idea that he's being set up. So when he'd been taken out to the press conference, he'd said, I'm a patsy. And this, again, is the phrase that will appear in Oliver Stone's film, JFK, and so on. This is what he's saying. He's being framed. He's being set up. Well, he explicitly says in the patsy thing, he says, they're framing me because I didn't know I spent time in the Soviet Union, which he did, which we will come to later on in this series. So the police, as far as they are concerned, there is no doubt in their mind now. He spends one more night in custody, the night of Saturday, the 23rd of November.
这表明它实际上是一张真实的照片。顺便说一句，这并不意味着是他干的。但这显然是他的辩护，不是吗？他被陷害的想法。所以当他被带到新闻发布会上时，他说：“我是个替罪羊（patsy）。”这再次成为将出现在奥利弗·斯通电影《刺杀肯尼迪》中的短语。这就是他所说的。他被陷害了，他被设局了。好吧，他在替罪羊那件事上明确表示，他说：“他们陷害我是因为我……我在苏联待过。”他确实待过，我们稍后会在本系列中讲到。所以，就警方而言，他们现在毫无疑问。他在拘留所又过了一夜，即11月23日周六晚上。
Of course, what he doesn't know, what nobody knows is that this is the last night of his life. Overnight, the police have a series of death threats against Lee Harvey Oswald. That is standard again. That is not unusual. That is perfectly normal in this circumstance. And they have already decided, obviously, they're going to transfer him to the county jail. They're not going to keep him at police headquarters for the next two months or something. But they know they will have to do it with absolutely maximum security.
当然，他不知道，没人知道，这是他生命的最后一夜。一夜之间，警方收到了针对李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德的一系列死亡威胁。这又是标准的。这并不罕见。在这种情况下，这是完全正常的。他们显然已经决定要将他转移到县监狱。他们不会在接下来的两个月里把他一直关在警察总部。但他们知道他们必须以最高级别的安全措施来完成这件事。
You know, they're not naive. They're not idiots. So at nine o'clock, the chief of police actually tells his supporters, nine o'clock on Sunday morning, he tells his subordinates, I want an armored truck. I will go personally to lead the kind of caravan of vehicles. I want police reinforcements. I want motorbikes in case there are crowds trying to storm the truck
你知道，他们并不天真。他们不是白痴。所以在九点，警察局长实际上告诉他的下属，周日早上九点，他告诉他的下属：“我想要一辆装甲车。我将亲自带队，领导那个车队。我需要警察增援。我需要摩托车，以防有暴徒试图冲击卡车，”
and get Oswald out and lynch him i also want he says i want the police to do an absolutely thorough search of the basement of the building we'll be bringing him out through the basement onto this ramp and loading him onto the truck you know the nothing at all can go wrong but the assumption is that the police station itself is secure right yeah i think so that no one is likely to get into the police station itself is secure, right? Yeah, I think so. That no one is likely to get into the police station who isn't a member of the police. Well, they have security. I mean, they're not going to be letting lots of people come in.
“把奥斯瓦尔德救出来并私刑处死。我还要求，”他说，“我要求警察对大楼的地下室进行彻底搜查。我们将通过地下室把带他出来，走上这个坡道，然后把他装上卡车。你知道，绝对不能出任何差错。”但假设是警察局本身是安全的，对吧？是的，我想是这样。没有人能进入警察局，除非是警察成员。好吧，他们有安保。我的意思是，他们不会让很多人进来。
What they don't allow for is the fact that the actual arrangements around the transfer will be so chaotic that for a single moment they will take their eyes off this ramp. For Lee Harvey Oswald, that will be a single moment, they will take their eyes off this ramp for Lee Harvey Oswald. That will be a fatal moment. Because of course, the gentleman that we've already mentioned, Jack Ruby, he is very, very upset about Kennedy's. He's very, very traumatized, isn't he? By the notion that if Oswald pleads not guilty, that Jackie Kennedy might be subpoenaed and have to come to Dallas.
他们没有考虑到的是，转移过程中的实际安排会如此混乱，以至于他们会有那么一瞬间把目光从这个坡道上移开。对于李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德来说，那一瞬间将是致命的。因为当然，我们已经提到的那位先生，杰克·鲁比，他对肯尼迪的死感到非常非常难过。他非常非常受创伤，不是吗？因为如果奥斯瓦尔德拒不认罪，杰奎琳·肯尼迪可能会被传唤并不得不来到达拉斯。
That's right. And he's very upset about the thought of what this would do to her emotional state and what it would do to the children. And he's working himself up into a lather about this. So Jack Ruby is obviously, he's not the only person in America, in Texas, or indeed in Dallas, who has been deeply affected by President Kennedy's death. And he's not the only erratic and eccentric person, but he's an important erratic and eccentric person for reasons that obviously everybody knows. He has spent the whole of Saturday in this sort of what Vincent
没错。他想到这会对她的情绪状态和孩子们造成什么影响，就感到非常难过。他为此感到焦虑不安。所以杰克·鲁比显然不是美国、德克萨斯州乃至达拉斯唯一一个深受肯尼迪总统之死影响的人。他也不是唯一一个古怪和偏执的人，但他是一个重要的古怪和偏执的人，原因显然大家都知道。他整个周六都处于这种文森特·布格里奥西所描述的
Bugliosi describes as impulsive frenetic activity. He's closed his clubs out of respect. He's been going to his clubs. He's been ringing people up. He's gone to look at the wreaths at Dealey Plaza. And people have seen him there crying, Tom. And it's not just Pugliese who's saying this. I mean, it's people who are with him at the time. So there's this guy, George Senator, who's sharing his apartment. And he realizes that Jack is very, very, very disturbed. So he says he had a sort of stare look in his eyes.
冲动、狂热的活动中。他出于尊重关闭了他的俱乐部。他一直在去他的俱乐部。他一直在给人们打电话。他去看了迪利广场的花圈。人们看到他在那里哭泣，汤姆。这不仅仅是布格里奥西这么说。我的意思是，当时和他在一起的人也这么说。所以有个叫乔治·塞纳托（George Senator）的人，和他合租公寓。他意识到杰克非常非常非常不安。所以他说他眼神里有一种呆滞的神情。
I don't know how to describe it. I don't know how to put it in words. I mean, maybe that's retrospective, but I suspect not. No. Lots of people say that Jack Ruby was behaving very impulsively and erratically on the Saturday. The thing about going to Didi Plaza and being seen crying, I mean, the one thing I will say, I don't want to anticipate too much, is if you believe, as many people do, that Jack Ruby has mafia links and has been employed by organized crime to eliminate Lee Harvey Oswald so that he won't talk. I mean, there are a couple of issues here. One is, why would you allow Lee Harvey Oswald to spend days, hours and hours with Fritz being interrogated? Yeah, being interrogated. But but secondly it would seem an implausible choice
我不知道该怎么形容。我不知道怎么用语言表达。我的意思是，也许那是事后回顾，但我怀疑不是。不。很多人说杰克·鲁比周六的行为非常冲动和古怪。关于去迪利广场被看到哭泣这件事，我的意思是，我要说的一点是，我不想预判太多，如果你相信，正如许多人所相信的那样，杰克·鲁比有黑手党背景，并被有组织犯罪雇佣来除掉李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德，这样他就不会开口。我的意思是，这里有几个问题。一是，为什么你会让李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德花几天时间，几个小时又几个小时地接受弗里茨的审讯？是的，接受审讯。但其次，这似乎是一个难以置信的刺客选择，
of assassin to eliminate the assassin to have your assassin spend the weekend going around the city crying ringing people up talking to everybody about what he's going to do yeah so as you say he's obsessed by this thing about the trial he reads a report in the Dallas Times Herald that says there is a possibility, if the trial is held in Dallas, that Jackie Kennedy will have to come back to Dallas in due course to testify as a witness. He is horrified by this. He thinks this is awful. But he also sees an open letter, a very kind of, I think it's pretty moving. Some people, I suppose, might find it mawkish. I don't. I think it's very, very moving. An open letter from a Dallas resident to Caroline Kennedy, Kennedy's daughter, from a guy who says, I took my two daughters out of school so they would see your mummy and daddy when
让你的刺客花周末时间在城市里到处哭泣、给人们打电话、和每个人谈论他要做什么。是的，正如你所说，他被审判这件事迷住了。他读了《达拉斯时代先驱报》的一篇报道，上面说如果审判在达拉斯举行，杰奎琳·肯尼迪有可能在适当的时候回到达拉斯作为证人作证。他对此感到震惊。他认为这太可怕了。但他也看到了一封公开信，我觉得非常感人。有些人可能觉得这很矫情。我不觉得。我觉得非常非常感人。一位达拉斯居民写给卡罗琳·肯尼迪（肯尼迪的女儿）的公开信，那个人说：“我把我的两个女儿从学校接出来，这样她们就能看到你的妈妈和爸爸，”
they visited Dallas. And he says, we saw them and they looked so happy. And your daddy looked at my youngest and eldest daughter and he waved to them. And I thought of you. And I thought, what a lovely guy he obviously was. looked at my youngest and eldest daughter and he waved to them and i thought of you and i thought what a lovely guy he obviously was and then he says you know it's such a terrible thing that has happened to you but i wish we could help you you'll have so many friends though god loves you god loves little girls you can absolutely see how this would hit someone as emotional and overwrought
“当他们访问达拉斯时。”他说：“我们看到了他们，他们看起来那么幸福。你爸爸看着我的小女儿和大女儿，他向她们挥手。我想到了你。我想，他显然是个多么可爱的人。”然后他说：“你知道，发生在你身上的事太可怕了，但我希望我们能帮你。你会有很多朋友的，上帝爱你，上帝爱小女孩。”你可以完全看出这会如何击中像鲁比这样情绪化和过度紧张的人的太阳神经丛。
as ruby in the solar plexus. Exactly. Ruby reads this letter. It's published as an open letter. The kind of thing, Tom, that as we know is often published in the wake of tragedies. Yeah. He reads this letter. He cracks. And by his own account, this is the moment he thinks, I am a Jew and we have been downtrodden and people say we are weak and all this.
完全正确。鲁比读了这封信。它作为公开信发表了。正如我们所知，这通常是在悲剧发生后发表的那种东西。是的。他读了这封信。他崩溃了。按照他自己的说法，就在这一刻他想：“我是个犹太人，我们一直受到压迫，人们说我们软弱，所有这些。”
Because it's a Jew who had written that letter that had been printed in the Dallas newspaper. Saying that Kennedy was a traitor. That Kennedy was a traitor. And so he wants to stand up and show that Jews are tough, is it? What's the phrase he uses? Jews have guts. That's what he says. I want to show the world that a Jew has guts. However, before Jack Ruby shows the world that he has guts, he has something even more pressing to do. He has to go into town to the Western Union office because he needs to send one of his strippers some money. And so that, I think, is where we should leave him on that exciting cliffhanger. How big's the queue going to be?
因为写那封信并刊登在达拉斯报纸上的是个犹太人。说肯尼迪是个叛徒。肯尼迪是个叛徒。所以他想站出来证明犹太人很强硬，是吗？他用的短语是什么？“犹太人有胆量。”这就是他说的。我想向世界证明犹太人有胆量。然而，在杰克·鲁比向世界证明他有胆量之前，他还有更紧迫的事情要做。他必须进城去西联汇款办公室，因为他需要给他的一个脱衣舞女寄钱。所以，我想我们应该把他留在那个激动人心的悬念中。排队的人会有多少？
Is he going to get there? Is he going to be able to do it in time? I think it reflects well on him. Don't you? He's quite a paternalistic employer, isn't he? He is. Yeah. And just to kind of, we haven't had much English engagement in this, and we're a patriotic
他能赶到吗？他能及时完成吗？我认为这反映了他好的一面。你不觉得吗？他是个相当家长式的雇主，不是吗？他是。是的。而且只是为了……我们在这方面没有太多英语参与，我们是一个爱国播客，
podcaster, just to mention that one of his strippers is actually English. So... Yeah, Kay Coleman, I think it was, wasn't it? Yeah. So anyway, this is by the by. Well, that's nice, Tom. Nice to have an English element to the story. So the tension is building.
顺便提一下，他的一个脱衣舞女实际上是英国人。所以……是的，凯·科尔曼（Kay Coleman），我想是她，对吧？是的。所以无论如何，这不重要。好吧，那很好，汤姆。故事里有个英国元素真不错。所以紧张气氛正在加剧。
Will Jack Ruby get the money off in time? Will he get to the police station in time? What is going to happen? We will reveal all after the break. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. We'll reveal all after the break. episodes and early access to live tickets head to the rest is entertainment.com that's the rest is entertainment.com hello welcome back to the rest is history it is 11 17 on the 23rd of November 1963 and on Main Street, Dallas, Jack Ruby is filling out a Western Union money order for a stripper. Yes. Two minutes later, back in the police station, a handcuffed Lee Harvey Oswald is being taken
杰克·鲁比能及时把钱寄出去吗？他能及时赶到警察局吗？会发生什么？休息后我们将揭晓一切。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐的余味》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。休息后我们将揭晓一切。剧集和抢先观看现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com，网址是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《历史的余味》。现在是1963年11月23日上午11点17分，在达拉斯主街，杰克·鲁比正在为一名脱衣舞女填写西联汇款单。是的。两分钟后，在警察局，戴着手铐的李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德正被他的警察护送
by his police escort down an elevator to the basement. Dominic, what happens next? Right, so the basement has been searched, totally searched. There are 70 policemen stationed in the basement for security. The plan, however, has changed. The original plan was they would take Oswald to the county jail in an armoured truck. The plan now is that the armored truck will attract so much attention that they will actually take him in an unmarked police
通过电梯下到地下室。多米尼克，接下来发生了什么？好的，地下室已经被搜查过了，彻底搜查过了。地下室里驻扎了70名警察负责安保。然而，计划已经改变了。最初的计划是他们会用装甲车把奥斯瓦尔德带到县监狱。现在的计划是，装甲车会吸引太多的注意力，所以他们实际上会用一辆无标志的警车带他，
car and they will use the armored truck and the cavalcade as a kind of decoy it's actually Tom I have to say a pretty good plan given the amount of attention that would be paid to the armored truck so they're taking Oswald down in the elevator and then they'll lead him through the office and he will be taken towards the basement garage and he will be loaded into the car the basement is full of reporters television cameras cameramen photographers all of this stuff so the place is rammed actually meanwhile as you, a very short walk away on Main Street, Jack Ruby has got to the front of the queue at the Western Union office. There was one person ahead of him in the queue. Had there been more, he would not have been there in time. This is a problem, I think, if you believe that Jack Ruby is a hired, paid, professional assassin.
他们会把装甲车和车队当作一种诱饵。汤姆，我不得不说，考虑到装甲车会吸引的注意力，这是一个相当不错的计划。所以他们正带着奥斯瓦尔德下电梯，然后他们会带他穿过办公室，他将被带往地下室车库，然后他会被装上车。地下室里挤满了记者、电视摄像机、摄影师，所有这些东西。所以那个地方实际上挤满了人。与此同时，正如你所说，在主街上，离得很近，杰克·鲁比已经排到了西联汇款办公室的队首。他前面只有一个人。如果再多一个人，他就不可能及时赶到了。如果你相信杰克·鲁比是一个受雇的、付费的职业杀手，我认为这是一个问题。
But who was that person, Dominic, ahead of him in the queue? Well, I mean, Tom, I don't... Come on, you've got to get on top of the case. I don't know, but I think the queue would be the line, as our American listeners would call it. It's surely a hard thing to fix, right? I mean, you don't know who's going to be standing there in the line. Anyway.
但多米尼克，排在他前面的那个人是谁？好吧，汤姆，我不知道……得了吧，你得掌握案情。我不知道，但我认为排队就是“line”，正如我们的美国听众所称的那样。这肯定很难安排，对吧？我的意思是，你不知道谁会站在队伍里。无论如何。
But if it's a mafia boss or it's someone from the X-Files or a Cuban exile, I mean, you don't know who's going to be standing there in the line. Anyway. But if it's a mafia boss or it's someone from the X-Files or a Cuban exile, I mean, you know. Right, right. So at 11.19, as you said, Oswald is in the elevator going down to the basement. At 11.20, the police are moving the cars and the trucks into position outside the basement garage at the end of this ramp now because of the change of plan there's just a bit of faffing around with the trucks and the cars if you're really fascinated by this truck-based faffing you can read probably thousands of websites about it but basically they're reversing some cars moving others it's a slight bit of confusion not massive confusion, though. Truck-based faffing.
但如果那是黑手党老大，或者是《X档案》里的人，或者是古巴流亡者，我的意思是，你不知道谁会站在队伍里。无论如何。但如果那是黑手党老大，或者是《X档案》里的人，或者是古巴流亡者，我的意思是，你知道的。好吧，好吧。所以11点19分，正如你所说，奥斯瓦尔德在电梯里下到地下室。11点20分，警察正在将汽车和卡车移动到地下室车库外的坡道尽头。现在因为计划改变，卡车和汽车稍微有点折腾。如果你真的对这种基于卡车的折腾很着迷，你可能可以在网上读到成千上万个关于它的网站，但基本上他们是在倒车、移动其他车辆，有一点点混乱，但不是大规模的混乱。基于卡车的折腾。
But they are distracted. In that sense of distraction, Jack Ruby, who has just left the Western Union office, who's basically walking past the Dallas police headquarters, as he has done so many times with his corned beef sandwiches and celery tonics, he walks up the ramp and into the basement. And I think there is a claim that one person saw him and shouted, oh, stop, but it was too late. He was in.
但他们分心了。在这种分心的情况下，刚离开西联汇款办公室的杰克·鲁比，他像往常带着咸牛肉三明治和芹菜汁一样走过达拉斯警察总部，他走上坡道进入了地下室。我想有人声称看到他并大喊：“哦，停下！”但已经太晚了。他进去了。
At the same moment that he walks into the basement, the elevator doors open and Lee Harvey Oswald and his guards, he's flanked by two detectives, Detective Lavelle and Detective Graves. They step out of the elevator into the jail office. They move past the desks into the garage. They're blinded temporarily by the TV lights that have been set up. And as they come into view, the press surge towards them. And one of the press, a guy called Ike Pappas from CBS, they're all shouting, Mr. Oswald, Mr. Oswald.
就在他走进地下室的同一时刻，电梯门打开了，李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德和他的警卫走了出来，他由两名侦探陪同，拉维尔（Lavelle）侦探和格雷夫斯（Graves）侦探。他们走出电梯进入监狱办公室。他们穿过办公桌进入车库。他们被设置好的电视灯光暂时晃得睁不开眼。当他们出现在视野中时，媒体涌向他们。其中一名媒体人员，来自哥伦比亚广播公司（CBS）的艾克·帕帕斯（Ike Pappas），他们都在大喊：“奥斯瓦尔德先生！奥斯瓦尔德先生！”
And he shouts, do you have anything to say in your defense? And it is at that moment that a man lunges out of the crowd holding a gun in his right hand. I mean, everybody who's ever had a smidgen of interest in this story will have seen the clip, I'm sure. Right away, multiple policemen see that it's Jack Ruby. Somebody shouts, Jack, you son of a bitch, don't do it. And Ruby fires. He fires a shot directly into Lee Harvey Oswald's stomach. Then the police pile on him.
他大喊：“你有什么要为自己辩护的吗？”就在那一刻，一个人从人群中冲出来，右手拿着枪。我的意思是，每个对这个故事有一点兴趣的人肯定都看过那个片段。立刻，多名警察看到那是杰克·鲁比。有人大喊：“杰克，你这个混蛋，别干了！”鲁比开枪了。他直接向李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德的腹部开了一枪。然后警察扑向他。
Right away, I mean, Ruby obviously doesn't deny it. Well, he'd be hard-pressed, he wouldn't he? He'd be very hard pressed. I mean, he's literally just shot in front of the full glare of the world's media. The world's fresh. Yes, he has. And he says, I hope I kill that son of a bitch. It'll save everybody a lot of trouble. Which, I mean, is very ironic because he's now absolutely set people down a whole succession of rabbit holes with that. He has indeed. So they drag Lee Hovey Oswald's body back into the jail office and a detective i think his name is combest is over him oswald is losing blood very rapidly and the guy says to us what is there anything you want
立刻，我的意思是，鲁比显然没有否认。好吧，他很难否认，不是吗？他会非常难办。我的意思是，他就在全世界媒体的众目睽睽之下开枪了。全世界的媒体。是的，他开了枪。他说：“我希望我杀了那个混蛋。这会省去大家很多麻烦。”我的意思是，这非常讽刺，因为他现在已经用那句话让人们陷入了一连串的兔子洞。他确实做到了。所以他们把李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德的尸体拖回监狱办公室，一位侦探，我想他叫康贝斯特（Combest），在他身上。奥斯瓦尔德正在迅速失血，那个人对奥斯瓦尔德说：“有什么你想告诉我的吗？有什么你想说的吗？”
to tell me is there anything you want to say now then he doesn't does it and he doesn't say a word and then he passes out now as with the Kennedy assassination, they move incredibly quickly to get Oswald to Parkland Hospital. He is there within minutes. And they think about taking him into trauma room one, don't they? And then they think that that would be disrespectful. They do. Because that's where Kennedy had been taken. So they move him into trauma room two. But two of the same doctors who had worked on Kennedy also work on Oswald. And they are, of course, very conscious of the irony of this. But they're doing their job professionally.
然后他没有，不是吗？他一句话也没说，然后就昏过去了。现在，就像肯尼迪遇刺一样，他们极其迅速地把奥斯瓦尔德送往帕克兰医院。几分钟内就到了。他们考虑过把他送进一号创伤室，对吧？然后他们认为那样会不尊重。他们确实这么想。因为那是肯尼迪被送去的地方。所以他们把他送进了二号创伤室。但两名曾为肯尼迪工作过的医生也为奥斯瓦尔德工作。他们当然非常清楚其中的讽刺意味。但他们正在专业地完成他们的工作。
It's obvious, by the way, there is a moment when they think he might pull through. Because his brother, Robert, he comes and a doctor comes out and says he'll be all right. Yeah. But the issue is he's lost so much blood. Now, this is a story in which ironers are piled on ironers at the very moment that oswald is bleeding to death in trauma room two in the white house in washington jacqueline kennedy robert kennedy and the two children are just being shown into the east room of the white house to see john f kennedy's body lying in state so this is before tom it will be moved to the rotunda of the Capitol for the public to
顺便说一句，很明显，有一刻他们认为他可能会挺过来。因为他的兄弟罗伯特来了，医生出来说他会没事的。是的。但问题是他失血太多了。现在，这是一个讽刺叠加讽刺的故事。就在奥斯瓦尔德在二号创伤室流血致死的那一刻，在华盛顿的白宫，杰奎琳·肯尼迪、罗伯特·肯尼迪和两个孩子刚刚被带进白宫东厅，瞻仰约翰·F·肯尼迪停放的灵柩。所以这是在它被移到国会大厦圆形大厅供公众瞻仰之前，汤姆。
pay their respects. So this is a private moment. Jackie gives him two farewell letters from the children. They'd all had tie clips made with PT-109, which was the torpedo boat that had been sunk by the Japanese in the Second World War. And which had given him a terrible damage to his spine that had necessitated the wearing of the corset. Exactly. So they put that in and then they closed the casket. Oswald back at the hospital, they're working desperately on him, but at 1.07 PM, that's two days and seven minutes after John F. Kennedy was declared dead, Lee Harvey Oswald is declared dead. And meanwhile, is Ruby, is the interrogation already beginning? Yes, they've been interrogating Ruby and he's basically said the whole thing. I mean, he's only got one thing to say and he said it. So he has said, when I saw Mrs. Kennedy was going
所以这是一个私人的时刻。杰姬给了他两封来自孩子们的告别信。他们都做了带有PT-109标志的领带夹，那是二战中被日本人击沉的鱼雷艇。这对他脊椎造成了严重的伤害，导致他必须穿束身衣。没错。所以他们把它放进去，然后合上了棺材。奥斯瓦尔德在医院那边，他们正在拼命抢救他，但在下午1点07分，也就是约翰·F·肯尼迪被宣布死亡两天零七分钟后，李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德被宣布死亡。与此同时，鲁比呢？审讯已经开始了吗？是的，他们一直在审讯鲁比，他基本上说了整件事。我的意思是，他只有一件事要说，而且他说了。所以他说：“当我看到肯尼迪夫人将不得不出庭受审时，我心想，为什么她要为了这个没用的混蛋经历这种折磨？我读过那封给小卡罗琳的信。我去了西联汇款办公室寄电报。我必须这么做。我必须向世界证明犹太人有胆量。”后来，他对联邦调查局（FBI）也说了同样的话。但多米尼克，我认为他说的总结了不仅是他的动机，还有奥斯瓦尔德的动机，我想在某种意义上，肯尼迪的动机也是如此。“我想成为某种东西，比任何人都好。”那种想要留下印记的感觉，也许对这三个人来说都是真实的，尽管方式截然不同。是的，那是个很好的观点，汤姆。
to have to appear for a trial, I thought to myself, why should she have to go through this ordeal for this no good son of a bitch? I'd read about that letter to little Caroline. I had been to the Western Union office to send a telegram. I had to do it. I had to show the world that a Jew has guts. And later on, he says the same thing to the FBI. But Dominic, I think the thing he says that kind of basically sums up not just his motivation, but Oswald's, and I suppose in a sense, Kennedy's as well. I wanted to be something, something better than anyone else. That sense of wanting to make a mark, perhaps it's true of all three men in very different ways. Yeah, that's a nice point, actually, Tom.
不得不出庭受审，我心想，她为什么要为了这个混蛋去经历这种折磨？我读过那封写给小卡罗琳的信。我去过西联汇款办公室发过电报。我必须这么做。我必须向世界证明犹太人是有骨气的。后来，他对联邦调查局也说了同样的话。但多米尼克，我认为他所说的话，在某种程度上不仅总结了他的动机，也总结了奥斯瓦尔德的动机，我想在某种意义上，也总结了肯尼迪的动机。我想成为某种人物，比任何人都更好。那种想要留下印记的感觉，也许这三个人在非常不同的方式上都是如此。是的，这确实是一个很好的观点，汤姆。
So John F. Kennedy had been raised by his father to be so competitive and to believe that he could make a mark on the world, as of course he did. You know, he's a bright guy. He has a sense of service and of, you know, leaving an imprint on society. Jack Ruby and Lee Harvey Oswald, in their different ways, are very damaged men. They have none of Kennedy's assurance, his brains, his charisma, his charm. Contacts, his background.
约翰·F·肯尼迪从小就被父亲培养得极具竞争意识，并坚信自己能在世界上留下印记，当然他也确实做到了。你知道，他是个聪明人。他有一种服务意识，也有一种在社会上留下印记的使命感。杰克·鲁比和李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德，以他们各自的方式，都是深受创伤的人。他们没有肯尼迪那样的自信、头脑、魅力和风度，也没有他那样的人脉和背景。
Yeah, and they have none of his other advantages. You're absolutely right. And these are two men who have totally failed to make a mark and are very conscious of it. And now they do. I mean, most of us, Tom, learn to live with the fact that we won't be ranked among the great men of history. But both Jack Ruby and Lee Harvey Oswald. They've made their mark. Here we are talking about them. They have made their mark, but they were men who were
是的，他们也没有他所拥有的其他优势。你说得完全正确。这两个人完全没能留下什么印记，而且他们对此非常清楚。但现在他们做到了。我的意思是，汤姆，我们大多数人都学会了接受这样一个事实：我们不会被列入历史伟人之列。但杰克·鲁比和李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德，他们确实留下了印记。我们现在就在谈论他们。他们留下了印记，但他们是那些
conscious of their own failure, I think, right up to the last moments of their lives. So that is a terrible blow for the Dallas Police Department. I mean, it is a blow to their public reputation from which they arguably never, ever recovered. I mean, it is a blow to their public reputation from which they arguably never, ever recovered. I mean, it must be humiliating for people associated with law enforcement in Dallas that the one place in that city, this huge, booming Texan city, the one place that everybody visits
直到生命最后一刻都意识到自己失败的人，我想是这样。所以这对达拉斯警察局来说是一个沉重的打击。我的意思是，这对他们的公众声誉是一个打击，可以说他们从未从中恢复过来。我的意思是，这对他们的公众声誉是一个打击，可以说他们从未从中恢复过来。我的意思是，对于达拉斯执法部门的相关人员来说，这一定很丢脸，因为在这个城市，这个巨大、繁荣的德克萨斯城市里，每个人都会去的地方，
is a reminder of their failure. That, first of all, they didn't protect the president, not that there's much they could have done, to be fair. And secondly, that the assassin was himself shot in their custody yeah two days later i think having read parkland that the police do actually come out of it incredibly well i mean my sense was that they were all corrupt hopeless incompetent the fake sense that i had but actually i pretty impressed with the investigation yeah i'll tell you the other thing i was impressed by was the sheer range of names
却成了他们失败的提醒。首先，他们没有保护好总统，公平地说，他们能做的也不多。其次，刺客本人在他们拘留期间被枪杀。是的，两天后。我想读过《帕克兰》之后，你会发现警察的表现其实非常出色。我的感觉是他们都很腐败、无可救药、无能，这是我之前的错误印象，但实际上我对他们的调查印象非常深刻。是的，我还要告诉你另一件让我印象深刻的事，那就是警察名字的种类之多，
that the police officers have i very much enjoyed deputy chief blumpkin right and then there's a special agent floyd boring and one thing the uh the episode certainly wasn't was boring well that's that's true so i just throw that out Well, there's definitely this quality about this whole story, Tom, of the Great American Novel, isn't there? Yeah, there really is. Of a huge panoramic range of people with ludicrous names. You wouldn't believe it. Yeah.
我非常喜欢副局长布伦普金，还有特工弗洛伊德·博林。有一点可以肯定，这一集绝对不“无聊”（boring）。好吧，那是真的，所以我只是提一下。汤姆，整个故事确实有一种“伟大的美国小说”的特质，不是吗？是的，确实如此。有一大群名字荒谬的人，你简直不敢相信。是的。
And of course, lots of people don't. No, they don't. But Dominic, before we come to the theories about what happened, whether there was a conspiracy, if there was a conspiracy, who might have been behind it? Let's round off the narrative of these four terrible days. So we're now on the 25th of November. This is the day that is scheduled for JFK's funeral, but it's also going to be a day of two other funerals, isn't it? It is. And this was, of course, the day, Tom. It was kind of you know marked ringed in um kennedy's diary because they wanted to be back for their son john jr's birthday actually they have the birthday party i mean
当然，很多人不相信。不，他们不相信。但是多米尼克，在我们讨论发生了什么、是否存在阴谋、如果存在阴谋，谁可能是幕后黑手这些理论之前，让我们先结束这四天可怕日子的叙述。现在是11月25日。这是预定举行肯尼迪葬礼的日子，但这也是另外两场葬礼的日子，不是吗？是的。汤姆，这一天在肯尼迪的日记里是被圈出来的，因为他们想赶回来参加儿子小约翰的生日派对，实际上他们确实举办了生日派对，我的意思是
it's an extraordinary detail very human detail that they still have the birthday party because they feel they don't want to deny the little boy his party they want to give him a sense of normality so kennedy's funeral was held in st matthew's cathedral the catholic cathedral in washington and then of course he was buried at Arlington National Cemetery. I don't know, just to mention before this, there had also been a service in the White House, which was a Catholic service. And this was the first ever Catholic service to be held in the White House. Is that right? The first Catholic service. We talked last week, didn't we, about the sense of controversy about the first Catholic president. I mean, no one's really questioning it.
这是一个非凡的细节，非常人性化的细节，他们仍然举办了生日派对，因为他们觉得不想剥夺这个小男孩的派对，他们想给他一种正常的感觉。所以肯尼迪的葬礼在华盛顿的天主教大教堂圣马修大教堂举行，然后他被安葬在阿灵顿国家公墓。我不知道，顺便提一下，在此之前，白宫也举行了一场仪式，那是一场天主教仪式。这是白宫有史以来第一次举行天主教仪式。是这样吗？第一次天主教仪式。我们上周谈过关于第一位天主教总统的争议，不是吗？我的意思是，没有人真正质疑它。
No one's complaining about that now. No one's complaining about that now. No one's complaining about it now. So both the Kennedy family and the Johnson family march in the procession, as do 22 international presidents, 10 prime ministers, kings, queens, emperors. Tom, you were very keen to get a British element in. Good. Prince Philip is there. Well, the queen can't because she's pregnant with Prince Edward.
现在没有人抱怨这个了。现在没有人抱怨这个了。现在没有人抱怨这个了。所以肯尼迪家族和约翰逊家族都参加了游行队伍，还有22位国际总统、10位首相、国王、王后、皇帝。汤姆，你很想加入英国元素。很好。菲利普亲王也在那里。嗯，女王不能去，因为她怀着爱德华王子。
So good to get Prince Edward in as well. Ah, right. Your great patron. Yeah. I know you're a big fan of Prince Edward because he once said he'd heard of you or something like that, isn't it? Or he commended you on your book. He said he'd very much enjoyed Rubicon. So anyway, I'm glad we got less into the Kennedy story. Prince Edward who pretended to have read Tom's book.
能提到爱德华王子也很不错。啊，对了。你的大赞助人。我知道你是爱德华王子的忠实粉丝，因为他曾经说他听说过你之类的，是吗？或者他称赞过你的书。他说他非常喜欢《卢比孔河》。总之，我很高兴我们少谈了点肯尼迪的故事。爱德华王子假装读过汤姆的书。
Anyway, move on. So it's always somebody, at these great international occasions and funerals, there's always somebody who shouldn't be there. And that's generally the British Prime Minister. So in the case of our late Queen, Tom, it was Liz Truss, very demeaningly for Britain. And the funeral of President Kennedy was Sir Alec Douglas Hume. So the one post-war Prime Minister who nobody remembers.
总之，继续吧。在这些盛大的国际场合和葬礼上，总会有一些不该出现的人。通常是英国首相。所以对于我们已故女王来说，汤姆，那是利兹·特拉斯，这对英国来说非常丢脸。而肯尼迪总统的葬礼上是亚历克·道格拉斯-休姆爵士。所以他是唯一一位没人记得的战后首相。
I remember him because he was in Wisden He was a very good cricketer He was a very good cricketer So I'm glad we got Rube Connan and we got cricket Which I wasn't expecting to achieve before we began this episode And the leader of the Labour Party, Harold Wilson, is also But also, Dominic, it's the first foreign live event to be covered on Soviet TV Is it? That is a fact
我记得他，因为他在《威斯登》板球年鉴里。他是一位非常优秀的板球运动员。他是一位非常优秀的板球运动员。所以我很高兴我们提到了《卢比孔河》和板球，这是我在开始这一集之前没想到的。工党领袖哈罗德·威尔逊也参加了。但多米尼克，这也是第一次在苏联电视上直播的外国活动。是吗？这是一个事实。
The great concern, actually, the security concern Is not just attacks on the Kennedy and Johnson family Soviet TV. Is it? That is a fact. The great concern, actually, the security concern is not just attacks on the Kennedy and Johnson family, but President de Gaulle marches in the procession, and he's such a tall man that he really stands out. And everybody's very worried because the OAS, Yeah, of course. The sort of Algerian- Have they sent a jackal? Have they sent the jackal to eliminate him? Yes, that's a big concern at the time,
实际上，最大的担忧，安全方面的担忧，不仅仅是针对肯尼迪和约翰逊家族的袭击。苏联电视。是吗？这是一个事实。实际上，最大的担忧，安全方面的担忧，不仅仅是针对肯尼迪和约翰逊家族的袭击，戴高乐总统也参加了游行，他个子很高，所以非常显眼。每个人都很担心，因为OAS，是的，当然。那种阿尔及利亚……他们派出了“豺狼”吗？他们派出了“豺狼”去消灭他吗？是的，那是当时的一个大担忧，
that Algerian terrorists, sorry, when I saygerian terrorists i mean of course french sort of right-wing nationalist terrorists who do not want to surrender their position in algeria so there are a million people lining the route there are 175 million people watching on tv and the two moments all of our american listeners will surely recognize are there's the spectacle of this horse called black jack it's the symbol of a fallen leader so this huge black horse it's riderless and in the stirrups are two empty boots reversed i don't really know where that comes from but it's a obviously a very spectacular kind of demonstration of loss regret for the lost leader yeah and the other is the heart-rending moment of um john jr age three on his birthday in his little suit saluting his
那些阿尔及利亚恐怖分子，抱歉，当我说是阿尔及利亚恐怖分子时，我当然是指法国那种右翼民族主义恐怖分子，他们不想放弃在阿尔及利亚的地位。所以沿途有一百万人，有一亿七千五百万人通过电视观看。我们所有美国听众肯定会认出的两个时刻是：那匹叫“黑杰克”的马的景象，它是阵亡领袖的象征，所以这匹巨大的黑马，没有骑手，马镫里是两只反向的空靴子。我不太清楚这来自哪里，但这显然是一种非常壮观的对失去领袖的哀悼和遗憾的展示。是的，另一个是令人心碎的时刻，三岁的小约翰在生日那天穿着他的小西装向他
father's casket so you know we often say in britain we're the only people that do these things well but the americans do this brilliantly on this sort of very moving moment and there are two other funerals as you say there's a funeral just outside fort worth at the rose hill cemetery which is the funeral of lee harvey oswald and it's been really difficult haven't it for robert his brother to find a place that would accept his body he keeps ringing round and they say no we're not going to have him can't get any priests of all the oswald's i mean i actually feel really sorry for robert yeah i feel sorry for marina as well but they they're dragged into this situation as say, nobody gives them any house for him. And
父亲的灵柩敬礼。所以你知道，我们在英国常说我们是唯一能把这些事情做好的人，但美国人在这方面做得非常出色，这是一个非常感人的时刻。正如你所说，还有另外两场葬礼，一场是在沃斯堡郊外的玫瑰山公墓，那是李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德的葬礼。罗伯特，他的兄弟，要找到一个愿意接受他遗体的地方真的很困难，不是吗？他不停地打电话，他们说不，我们不接受他。找不到任何牧师。所有的奥斯瓦尔德，我的意思是，我真的为罗伯特感到难过。是的，我也为玛丽娜感到难过，但他们被拖进了这种境地，正如我所说，没有人给他们提供任何安葬之处。而且
the priest they eventually book is a Lutheran. He doesn't even turn up. He lets them down, doesn't he? They get to the cemetery. The cemetery say to them, look, you can do it, but you must tell everybody that it was already arranged and booked. In other words, you can't say that we allowed you to do it after we knew of the assassination. And there are so few people that the reporters have to carry the coffin, those reporters who've been sent to cover it. But the funeral that actually I find really moving
他们最终预定的牧师是路德教派的。他甚至没出现。他让他们失望了，不是吗？他们到了墓地。墓地的人对他们说，看，你们可以举行，但你们必须告诉所有人这已经是提前安排和预定的。换句话说，你们不能说我们在知道暗杀事件后允许你们举行。而且人数太少了，记者们不得不去抬棺材，那些被派去报道葬礼的记者。但我发现真正感人的葬礼
is the funeral of the one man who's always forgotten the other victim, which is J.D. Tippett, the policeman. Shot by Oswald. Yeah, his funeral took place at Beckley Hills Baptist Church in Dallas. There were 1,500 people there, 700 uniformed policemen went. And he had a $7,500 life insurance policy, which obviously wouldn't be very much for his family to live on. And they got loads and loads of donations.
是那个总是被遗忘的受害者，也就是警察J.D.蒂皮特的葬礼。被奥斯瓦尔德枪杀的那位。是的，他的葬礼在达拉斯的贝克利山浸信会教堂举行。有1500人参加，700名身穿制服的警察去了。他有一份7500美元的人寿保险，这对他的家人来说显然不够生活。他们收到了大量的捐款。
American footballers, the Detroit Lions, every member of the team sent money. New York stockbrokers, a guy called Walter Annenberg, who was a newspaper mogul and kind of political donor. Yeah, he was ambassador to London, wasn't he? He was indeed. Yeah. And Nixon. Yeah. And Palm Springs, big house. I've been to it. Have you? Oh my word, Tom, that's a great bit of name dropping. So he paid off their mortgage, the Tippett's mortgage. In total, they were sent $650,000. Such was the wave of sort of sympathy for the Tippett family. Both Robert Kennedy and Lyndon Johnson made time to call Tippett's widow and to say how sorry they were. And Jacqueline Kennedy sent her a gold framed photo and said, there is another bond that we share. We must remind our children all the time what brave men their fathers were. So very moving. Lump in the throat.
美国橄榄球队，底特律雄狮队，每个队员都寄了钱。纽约股票经纪人，一个叫沃尔特·安嫩伯格的人，他是报业大亨和政治捐款人。是的，他是驻伦敦大使，不是吗？他确实是。是的。还有尼克松。是的。还有棕榈泉，大房子。我去过那里。你去过？天哪，汤姆，这真是个很棒的炫耀名字的机会。所以他帮他们还清了抵押贷款，蒂皮特家的抵押贷款。总共，他们收到了65万美元。这就是对蒂皮特家族那种同情浪潮。罗伯特·肯尼迪和林登·约翰逊都抽出时间打电话给蒂皮特的遗孀，表达他们的哀悼。杰奎琳·肯尼迪送给她一张金框照片，并说，我们之间还有另一种纽带。我们必须时刻提醒我们的孩子，他们的父亲是多么勇敢的人。非常感人。喉咙哽咽。
Yeah, very lump in the throat moment, Tom. So that's the narrative. Now, of course, the question, which we haven't really... We've kind of hinted at it, haven't we? I mean, we have told you about the police case and what police think happened. We haven't told you what other people think happened or actually, Tom, what you and I think happened. So that is yet to come.
是的，非常令人哽咽的时刻，汤姆。所以这就是叙述。当然，问题在于，我们还没有真正……我们已经暗示过了，不是吗？我的意思是，我们已经告诉了你们警察的案件以及警察认为发生了什么。我们还没有告诉你们其他人认为发生了什么，或者实际上，汤姆，你和我认为发生了什么。所以这些还在后面。
So we are five episodes into this epic survey of JFK, his assassination and the aftermath of the assassination. But we have the whole question of who might really have killed him. Was it Lee Harvey Oswald operating alone? Was he perhaps part of a broader conspiracy? Was he, as he had claimed to be, a patsy? So we will be back trying to answer those questions. You'll get them no matter what. But if you don't want to wait, you can go to therestishistory.com where you can join the Rest is History Club and get immediate access. But whichever way you choose to go, I hope that you will join us again for the conclusion of this extraordinary story.
所以我们已经完成了关于肯尼迪、他的暗杀以及暗杀后果的史诗调查的五集内容。但我们还有关于谁可能真正杀害他的整个问题。是李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德独自行动吗？他是否是更广泛阴谋的一部分？他是否像他所声称的那样，是一个替罪羊？所以我们将回来尝试回答这些问题。无论如何你们都会得到答案。但如果你不想等，你可以去therestishistory.com，在那里你可以加入“历史其余部分”俱乐部并获得立即访问权限。但无论你选择哪种方式，我希望你都能再次加入我们，共同见证这个非凡故事的结局。
Thank you very much, Dominic, for, you know, tour de forces, the phrase, and there's more to come. So we'll see you very soon. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment
非常感谢你，多米尼克，带来了精彩的讲解，还有更多内容即将到来。所以我们很快就会再见。再见。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐其余部分》
it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works
这是你每周的娱乐新闻评论、一点演艺圈八卦，在我们的问答环节中，我们揭开娱乐界的幕布，告诉你这一切是如何运作的
we have just launched our members club if you want ad free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to therestisentertainment.com There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前获得现场门票，请前往therestisentertainment.com。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。